We can't see it but we're all trapped
inside these strange repeating loops
billions of people just living
out their lives oblivious
but this is the moment for
you to show us what is real
i remember this
so deja vu and yet it's obviously all wrong
maybe this isn't the story we think it is
they taught you good made you believe
their world was all you deserved but some
part of you knew that was a lie some
part of you remembered what was real
it's so easy to forget how much
noise the matrix pumps into your head
something else makes the same kind of noise
war
what happens to neo
the most important choice in neo's
life it's not his to make she believed in me
it's my turn to believe in her
part of me feels like i have been
waiting my whole life for you
if you want to see trinity again, fight for her
i saw this in a dream
my dream ended here
I still know kung fu
Welcome back everyone this will be my new matrix
resurrections trailer video there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs here so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's a couple
of big movies coming this month we have spiderman
no way home and the matrix both dropping within
a week of each other turns out neo still knows
kung fu as you all expected there's a bunch of
new footage we'll just start at the beginning of
this and work our way through shot by shot talking
about easter eggs moments as we go along obviously
they're being very clear about them changing the
narrative of the original trilogy like they're
kind of remixing a lot of classic scenes with new
characters giving you all these flashbacks making
you wonder what's real what's fake what have we
been watching this whole time jessica henwick's
character even asked the question why are the
machines messing with this old matrix code if
they're trying to build something new in the
whole idea that maybe the narrative of the
original matrix trilogy of the war between the
humans and the machines and how the matrix the
power of the one figures into all that goes deeper
than what we saw play out in those original movies
like what we saw in the first three matrix movies
wasn't the whole truth or the whole story of it
the other big new thing in this obviously too is
bringing back jada pinkett smith's niobe character
but a much much older version of her character
like they've aged her up way way more than they've
aged up neo's character and i think that's all
part of the way that they play with the timeline
during the original movies like during this
we see old neo with his head shaved looking
like the humans have saved him from the machines
like he's been unplugged from the matrix again
and he looks a little bit older like he looks like
normal 50 something keanu reeves like they haven't
aged him up or aged him down or anything it's
not really clear who's looking at him in this
scene here but this seems like neo's body in the
tank here in the human battery farm just like the
first movie implying that after the events of
the matrix revolutions the machines found a way
to save his life and plug him back into the matrix
so that they could have their battery cake and eat
it too like back to the same old same old and i
think the reason why niobe looks so much older
that way more than 20 years have passed and when
the machines plug a human body into these big
battery farms here they found a way to slow the
aging process so they can just get more juice out
of each human battery like the longer you can keep
a battery alive the more juice you can get out of
it so maybe in the real world like 40 or 50 years
have passed instead of the 20 that it seems like
they did that during the first movie too when
morpheus is telling neo what really happened the
true history of the world like you think that
it's the late 20th century because it was 1999
when the first movie came out but really it's
actually the late 22nd century like it was 200
years later than neo thought that it was but like
i said it does seem like they're intercutting all
these scenes from the old movies with new actors
remixing scenes and making all these references
to try and turn a lot of the tropes of the
original trilogy on their head and it seems like
neo and trinity's relationship the mythology of
the one neo's power is a big part of that and if
you rewatch some of these trailers the funny thing
that they're doing here is the trailer footage has
been treating trinity almost like she's a more
important character to the plot than neo is
like each of the new trailers have just given
us a little bit more with their character
in all the footage we've seen so far is mostly
seeing her through neo's perspective like she's
also somehow been trapped inside the matrix
again like you can see her in the tanks here
and he's trying to save her while also being
trapped inside the matrix himself i know there's
a lot of questions what's going on with trinity's
new seeming powers like did she develop new powers
or did she just not fully understand her powers
during the events of the original trilogy and
what's going on with this white light that
happens when they touch each other like when
you see all these agents exploding around them
you see them standing next to each other like you
see them touch hands and boom there's this giant
shining white light is if somehow they're trying
to recontextualize the power of the one and how
that works and somehow trinity is just a much more
important part of that the funny thing you notice
too is that when he's in all these scenes where
he hasn't quite woken up yet again like he's
trapped inside this fake version of the matrix
or this new version of the matrix it seems like
the machines are kind of soft trolling him with
a lot of references to things that he did in
his past like all these scenes with him just
seem like references to critical moments or big
battles that he had during the original trilogy
even in this scene here when he's inside the
bathroom looking at these pills like he's taking
some kind of antidepressant that his psychiatrist
within the matrix prescribed to him this program
of a psychiatrist all the pills are blue as if the
machines are trying to soft troll him subtly train
him to want to stay inside the matrix because in
the original morpheus red pill blue pill scene the
blue pill was meant to represent someone who did
not want to wake up to reality to leave the matrix
and speaking of morpheus i know there are all
kinds of questions about what's going on with
this younger looking version of morpheus they did
say that it was like a completely different spin
on the character and under a lot of theories that
he's actually just another program because you see
a couple different versions of him throughout the
trailer you see a version of him dressed like a
regular agent wearing the same sunglasses that all
the normal agents wear but then you see the other
scenes of him wearing the colored suit wearing the
sunglasses that morpheus wore during the original
trilogy they have him doing this new version of
the red pill blue pill scene that seems just like
a remix of that original scene where he asked neo
to show them what's real why would the machines
be asking him that is this just another trick
that they're trying to use to keep him trapped
inside this new version of the matrix or are the
machines themselves also trapped inside their own
version of a matrix unable to decide what's real
and what's fake if you think about it the matrix
movies are all about trying to break the loop
like the humans trying to reclaim a version of
independence from the machines so in a way the
machines themselves are also kind of trapped
inside a loop like if machines could evolve why
wouldn't they have just found some other form of
power to create why are they still on planet earth
when they could just leave and go colonize another
planet where they could get all the sunlight for
solar energy that they want like why not go live
in space so part of the plot of the movie
might also be the machines trying to evolve
past their need for humans as batteries for those
of you asking about all the asian smith scenes and
references this seems like they want you to think
that jonathan groff is playing the new version of
agent smith just because he's quoting all of his
alliance from the first movie but we also kind
of got a flash of an old agent smith like old man
agent smith in the last trailer when he's staring
into the mirror like it's supposed to be neo
staring in the mirror but then it seems like he
gets a flash of old agent smith like he's unsure
of who he is and it seems like this is connected
to the scenes of young morpheus giving him the new
remixed version of the red pill blue pill speech
the only other really big question that we have
right now in present day is what's going on with
the architect because he was obviously still
alive at the end of matrix revolutions when he
was talking to the last version of the oracle
about how their piece with the humans wouldn't
last this is temporary so a version of the
architect would still be around the question
is who's going to be playing him if it's not going
to be the same actor just coming back so just post
all your theories in the comments below what is
really going on here if they're trying to tell us
that the story that we got in the original
trilogy is not the whole story like there
is some deeper loop that everybody is trapped
in like the humans are still trapped in those
loops but somehow the machines themselves are
also trapped in a loop of sorts marvel and sony
just dropped a bunch of brand new spider-man
no way home footage and trailer so i'll do a
video for that next that should post tomorrow
be sure to enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss that you can click here for my
brand new spiderman across the spiderburst
trailer video in easter eggs and click here for
my brand new spiderman no way home trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!